[music]
So uh I want to have a bit of a
different talk today because usually
we've always been seen as the consumer
company and 1X is amongst others a
consumer company but one of the really
big things to us has been over the last
decade the company is really about how
do we create an abundance of labor And
consumer has a very important part to
play in this. But of course, juvenoids
to me is about how do we create general
labor that can be deployed across
society. And while while the home has
the best data and I think also will be
one of the biggest markets in the end, I
do think there's a lot to say about when
you have this beautiful platform that
we've spent so long to really bring to
life and we're ready to scale this,
we're ready to manufacture this,
how do we let everyone help? How do we
kind of create this biggest possible
ecosystem around robotics? Because
general automation on robotics is
actually still quite small. And if we're
really going to come to an abundance of
labor, then I don't think this is
something we can do alone. And uh we
have some pretty big announcements
coming up in a couple of weeks that
you're going to get like a small taste
of today uh with respect to how we are
going to launch Neo as a developer
platform and really a call to action for
everyone to come build on this system
and see how we can create so much value
in society by by applying general
automation.
There we go. Okay.
So, there's been a lot of talk about
data, and I do think ultimately it's all
about data to get the models to be the
best. And one thing that we're pretty
proud of that I think is quite unique
about Neo is that it will be shipping
with full 22 degrees of freedom hands
just like we have, or we have like 25,
but it's pretty close. And we're super
excited to really see
what can all of you guys out there do
with this uh as you start developing and
also how can we make this even
accelerate what we're doing towards
consumer. So even though it might be a
bit confusing for us to talk about a
developer platform um as the consumer
company I also want to assure everyone
that hopefully here order a robot that
we are shipping to consumers this year.
It's going to be very rough and a lot of
fun and we're going to hand select a few
of you guys to be part of this and we're
going to scale it as fast as we
absolutely can but we want to do it in a
manner that is safe and that is uh
really responsible. So it's going to be
slow in the beginning but there's going
to be a few who gets the robot this year
and um through really enabling this
developer ecosystem. We also hope to
really accelerate the deployments into
the home and enable everyone to build
these small applications that they can
really either for fun or for useful
things get more out of their Neo.
So
if you think about it like this, um, 1X
is at this point really where we we have
a factory that is ready to scale and we
can produce a lot of robots
and this is all manufactured by the way
in Hayward in California, uh, except for
magnets which we buy from China. But um
it's it is really as far as I know one
of the few western alternatives to all
of this great hardware that comes out of
China. And if we now insist that we are
going to build all this ourself, then
it's going to take us a long while.
Because if you think about all of the
different things you want to do, right?
You have the very dear to me like the
developers that are like someone who
just begs mom and dad for a robot to try
to solve some unsolved problems to all
of the startups that we're talking to
that wants to automate on top of some of
these new platforms. You have all the
big research labs from the frontier labs
to more of the new uh neolabs to the
more classical integrators that want to
modernize and think about how can they
apply more general general systems. Um,
this is a lot of work and it can create
a lot of value today. And what we really
really want to make sure we focus on as
1x is we want to stay a product company.
So we do not want to be in all of these
markets working out how to integrate
against all of these different ERP
systems or MRP systems or other customer
applications. We would really like to
partner on this and we think this is a
great opportunity to really start
growing that ecosystem and of course we
will do some of it ourselves. So there
are a few hand selected customers that
we will do. But um I do really hope that
after this talk today there is a few
people in the room here that gives Neo a
try and really thinks is this something
I can build on? Is this something where
I can create value?
And
when you think about Neo, I want to talk
a bit about how Neo is different because
to be uh robotics has already always
really been about safety. And there is
of course no such thing as a fully safe
system if you are doing useful labor,
but you can do a lot to make your system
as safe as possible. And I'm very
excited to see that like how can we
apply robots, not just industrial
manufacturing. Now, of course, we're
using Neo in our own factory and we're
doing manufacturing, but this is such a
small subset of the world, right? And
ultimately, safety can be this very
complicated thing. But to me, safety is
quite simple. Safety defines where you
can go, like how useful can you be,
where can you apply your useful labor?
And the duel of that is of course where
can you gather data? How much data
diversity can you have? How can you
ensure that you have as many and as
broad experiences as possible to create
the most intelligent models? And I don't
think this is essentially talked enough
about because
if you want to build robots that are
safe then you need to build them a bit
differently than kind of like what I
would say like is the classical systems.
So you know
for the last 60 70 years we've generally
been building robots by having these
very heavily geared systems where you
can think about it like if I move my arm
like this and there's a gear inside here
that's 100 to1
this would spin at say 20,000 RPM and
that contains a lot of energy. Kinetic
energy is the velocity squared. And
through this, you create these robotic
systems that are quite strong, but
they're they're stiff and they're
they're heavy and they're high energy
and they work really well in these
industrial use cases, but they're not so
well designed for these unstructured
environments we humans live in. Now, of
course, we humans, we work very
differently. We're we're compliant,
we're low energy, we're safe, we're
soft, and we really wanted to build this
into the machine. And I kind of like to
look at this as a tech tree. And I'm
going to steal this from Jim Fan who
talked about the Age of Empires 2 tech
tree because I think it's a great
analogy. Um, if you start at the top and
you have a normal motor and then you use
this and you you select some high ratio
gears and you start having to add a lot
of sensors because now your system is
stiff, it's hard to modulate and it gets
kind of complicated and in the end you
can solve it for some tasks. But what we
really did was we started differently.
We invented a motor that is so strong
that we can pull on these tendons
instead and kind of like loosely
inspired by nature, create these
beautiful soft compliant systems that
are more energy efficient and can
interface with the world in a safe
manner. Now, of course, there's a lot of
smart people here today that know a lot
of technical things and have been in
robotics for a while. So, then you all
know that like tendons are amazing. Like
they're the holy grail of robotics, but
they don't really work that well. um
they're finicky, they break, they're not
that durable, they're really hard to
design around. There's a lot of unsolved
problems. And this is something we're
really really proud of because it's one
of those problems that
there's no one solution. We've been
grinding on this problem for a decade
and all the way from like new
discoveries in material science to how
to weave these things to how to process,
how to postprocess, how to design
around. We're finally at where we're
going to ship a product that I think we
can u have better durability and better
reliability than the classical geared
systems, but we can do it with this
tandem based system. Um, and I think
that's u really one of the biggest
achievements of 1x and what ultimately
of course I'll skip to this one. What
ultimately allowed us to build some
hands that I think is quite unique in
the capabilities because this is really
where even nature is not able to really
put all of your muscles in your hand for
your hand. You're kind of forced to do
tandem based system if you want to do
hands that are as strong and as dextrous
and as back drivable and force compliant
as human hands are. So this has been a
big project over the last um
having a bit of trouble with my videos
not playing. There's a hand supposed to
be in the background here, but uh you
saw the hand earlier. So, uh it's one of
those uh things that we've been working
on for a long time and that we're very
proud to ship now. And as part of the
as part of the developer platform, uh
we're going to ship Neo with the 22
degree of freedom hands and we're going
to try to create this homogeneous um
type of platform so that when we all
build on this, we will be able to not
only
solve some useful problems, but also try
to create some reproducibility across
research, which I'm very excited about.
And we're partnering quite heavily with
Nvidia here to build this out. And I
wanted to spend like two minutes talking
a bit about how I see the platform
because it's so diverse. So we want to
ensure that Neo can cater to all
different types of platform customers.
So that means we will have some
customers like the Frontier Labs who's
going to say like we don't really want
any of your guys' stuff. We just want
the robot and we're going to build our
own model and we're going to deploy that
and we're okay with that. Um we just
want to create the value that come from
building a great ecosystem. But we also
want to go all the other way and say
here's a system where you not only get
Neo, you get the data collection
equipment. So sensors like gloves,
cameras, etc. you can put on yourself,
VR uh control systems together with the
robots. So you can gather data. This
data automatically gets uploaded in our
cloud. Our cloud has some pretty good,
in our opinion, pretty good at least uh
models that we've trained to do
filtering, dense captioning, everything
that needs to happen with your data. So
you can select the right model that you
want to fine-tune. Hopefully you're
going to select the 1x world model. We
think that's the best model. Uh and but
there will be other models in there and
then deploy this into simulation, do
evaluation, deploy this on the robot and
solve your uh solve your problem so that
we can really cater to this very large
breath of the ecosystem from people who
want to build the entire stack
themselves to people who essentially
have a problem and they want to gather
some data to apply this to solve the
problem. And
I think this is incredibly important
because if you want to enable a large
ecosystem, it really starts by how do
you get the cost down. And even though
we're quite proud of being able to sell
Neo as a developer platform that is very
cost competitive.
Not everyone can afford a robot day one.
So we are really going to strive hard
for that when we're launching Neo from
day one. Sim simulation together with
Nvidia is a first class citizen. so that
you can do all of your experiments in
simulation and you can run all of your
models in simulation and see how far you
can push this before you actually even
have a robot. And one thing that I'm
incredibly excited about when it comes
to that and uh that we're going to roll
out towards the end of the year is what
I essentially what I call uh the NeoARM.
So we're planning to run actual
evaluation in real and the way this will
work is that we will have leaderboards
across different uh model evaluations
for different tasks and then we want to
automatically run a certain set of the
top models on these leaderboards
on actual Neos. So we will build
physical simulations where we have Neos
in resettable environments and we will
allow you guys to run your codes on
them. So that if you really come up with
some novel ways to solve some problems
on the learning side and you don't have
the money to buy robots, you can still
actually run this on real robots and get
actual deployed benchmarks so that we
can create fairness on structure and
score around benchmarks for robotics
which I think is something that's been
sorely missing. So
I want to end on the on the high side. I
think we're coming into some incredibly
exciting years. It's extremely hard to
predict whether we will have this kind
of like abundance of labor happening in
the next two years, three years or next
decade, but I'm pretty confident it's
not decades. And I think together we can
build such an incredible value by
working on this problem. And I can't
wait to see Neo and these other
embodiment that we will enable to be out
there in labs completing experiments,
closing the loop on scientific
experiments, which is such a big missing
thing for um
for uh in general AI right now, right?
We have the digital models, but we're
not able to build and run the
experiments to help out in healthcare,
to help out with companionship and
loneliness, to help out in factories, to
help out in across society in general.
And um I really hope some of you guys
want to help us on that journey and that
we can build this together because I do
think that the path to abundance through
robotics is going to be through platform
and developers and through building this
incredibly large ecosystem that will
enable us to crowdsource crowdsource
solving a lot of these problems. Thank
you.